c'est une petite boutique au cette route
de trouville voilà vingt ans maintenant
que la chiffo s'inscrit en toutes
lettres dans le tissu social canet cette
structure emploie jusqu'à cinquante et
une personnes en contrat à durée
déterminée d'insertion
encadrés par six salariés permanents et
vous êtes au coeur de l'atelier
d'insertion socioprofessionnelle nous
sommes dans l'arrière boutique de la
chiffo sur la plateforme logistique dans
ce service
on compte sept chauffeurs
manutentionnaire à tour de rôle et à
raison de deux employées par camion une
équipe part en tournée
ces seize conteneurs à peu près par vaux
on en a 65 à cabara semaine je crois
qu'on tient donc le se répartit sur eux
depuis 2011 et grâce à un accord passé
avec caen la mer la chiffre on peut
ainsi collecté les vêtements dont 65
bornes d'apport extérieur situé dans
l'agglomération caennaise en 2014
ces conteneurs ont permis de glaner 70 %
de dons soit 224 tonnes ce système de
collecte a donc fait ses preuves
pourtant la courbe semble
malheureusement s'inverser depuis
quelques temps
la frédéric c'est une c'est une bonne
collecte non c'est plutôt une mauvaise
la rencontre se contenir la il est plein
ils en avaient jusque là voir ça déborde
donc là c'est plutôt vie devra avoir le
double des bornes désespérément vides à
la chiffo le terrible constat est fait
depuis la fin de l'année 2014
et cela coïncide avec la diffusion d'un
reportage de l'émission envoyé spécial
au soir il ya de l'or dans nos armoires
le 20 novembre dernier
ce magazine évoqué le business lucratif
de la collecte du vêtement pour
certaines entreprises privées même
devenu un trafic mondial à l'époque
faute de dons suffisamment important la
chiffo avait vu son activité baisser de
l'ordre de 40 à 50% même conteneur deux
mois plus tard on constate à vue d'oeil
que les effets se font encore ressentir
là on puisse sur des stocks qu'on avait
qu'on avait assemblé depuis cet été sur
la sur la matière hiver on puisse dessus
choses qu'on ne sait jamais quoi et si
on nous coupe la matière première on
arrête toute activité voilà donc il faut
donner il faut le donner ce sont des
produits qui gêne qui embarrasse qui
servent de support de travail qui
servira provisionner une boutique
sociale et solidaire germes est toute
une mécanique économique que si
l'économie circulaire derrière et je
pense que si la communication à venir
les philosophies change mais faut
accélérer le mouvement
vous l'aurez compris à la chiffo le don
est d'utilité sociale en 2014 313 tonnes
de vêtements ont été récoltés grâce aux
bornes d'apport volontaire le don en
boutique ou bien encore par le biais des
partenaires tels que le secours
catholique
demain dernier rendez vous avec des
expertes du tissu les flics air de
l'atelier technique de la chiffo là même
où le vêtement et triés sur le volet
avant d'être mise en rayon à la boutique